el examen de matemáticas de liszt
incluye una pregunta para saber el
número de horas que estudió para el
examen cada alumno la siguiente gráfica
de dispersión muestra la relación entre
el número de horas que estudió el alumno
y su calificación para modelar esta
relación dibujamos una línea recta que
se ajusta a los datos no nos dicen cómo
lo hicieron para ajustar esta recta a
los datos pero simplemente viéndolo
parece como que si es una muy buena de
aproximación y ahora nos preguntan cuál
de las siguientes ecuaciones de líneas
rectas es la que mejor describe al
modelo podemos observar los datos por
aquí tenemos un alumno que nos dicen que
estudió un poquito más de media hora y
no le fue muy bien en el examen sacó 44
o un valor parecido luego por acá
tenemos otro alumno que estudió dos
horas para el examen y obtuvo una
calificación como de 64 ó 65 y luego nos
podemos ir a ver estos puntos por aquí
tenemos un alumno
qué estudio más de cuatro horas y obtuvo
una calificación como de 95 96 más o
menos así es que cada uno de estos
puntos representa a un alumno distinto y
luego ya que vieron la distribución de
estos datos decidieron que un buen
modelo es esta recta y ya con todos
estos datos decidieron que el mejor
modelo para esta relación era esta línea
recta y nos preguntan que cuál de estas
ecuaciones es la que describe mejor a
este modelo ahora lo que realmente nos
están preguntando aquí es cuál de estas
ecuaciones es la que se encuentra
gráfica da aquí así es que lo que
queremos es encontrar la ecuación de
esta línea y bueno parece como que la
ordenada al origen es 20 y todas estas
opciones tienen una ordenada al origen
de 20 por lo que esta información no nos
está ayudando demasiado pero bueno ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa con la pendiente
cuando aumentamos 1 a lo largo del eje x
cuando el cambio en x es 1 cuánto es el
cambio en g
bueno pues nos estamos moviendo de 20 a
40 entonces el cambio en g es 20
positivo así es que el cambio en g entre
el cambio en x qué es la pendiente para
este modelo en particular que ya está
ajustado a los datos es igual a 20 entre
16 y 20 entre 1 así es que esta es la
pendiente y ahora sí si nos fijamos en
las posibles ecuaciones hay una sola
ecuación que tiene una pendiente de 20
por lo que esta es la respuesta correcta
pero bueno ahora vamos con la siguiente
pregunta que nos dice usando esta
ecuación estima la calificación de un
alumno que estudió 3.8 horas así es que
nos vamos a 3.8 que es más o menos por
aquí
utilizando este modelo esta ecuación
queremos estimar la calificación de un
alumno que estudió 3.8 horas por lo que
desde aquí me voy directamente hacia
arriba y veo en donde se intersecta con
mi modelo en donde se interese acá con
la línea y parece como que obtiene una
calificación bastante alta como de 96
más o menos entonces vamos a escribir
por aquí 96 esta es mi estimación de la
calificación del alumno claro que
podemos obtener una estimación más
precisa en lugar de dibujar esta línea y
tratar de adivinar cuál es la
calificación que está estimando este
modelo podemos simplemente tomar el
número de horas que estudió el alumno y
sustituirlo en el lugar de x en esta
ecuación y entonces nos queda que la
calificación estimada por este modelo es
igual al 20 por 3.8
y eso en efecto nos queda igual a 96
ok entonces esta es la estimación de la
calificación de un alumno que estudia
3.8 horas según este modelo que nos
dieron desde el principio que tiene esta
ecuación pero por supuesto hay algunas
cosas con las que tenemos que tener
mucho cuidado ok
esta es simplemente una estimación es lo
que podemos esperar que un alumno saque
si estudia aproximadamente 3.8 horas y
también necesitamos tener mucho cuidado
a la hora de hacer extrapolaciones por
ejemplo si usamos este modelo para
predecir la calificación de una persona
que estudia 9 horas para el examen con
el modelo podemos estimar una
calificación de 200 puntos cuando eso no
es posible
así es que siempre tenemos que tener
mucho cuidado cuando hacemos
extrapolaciones con modelos y hay que
tomarlo por lo que es
es simplemente un modelo que estamos
ajustando a los datos que tenemos y
podemos utilizarlo para estimar algunas
calificaciones tener una buena idea de
qué calificación podemos obtener si
estudiamos cierto número de horas pero
el modelo solo está haciendo una
estimación de lo que podemos esperar
como resultado no nos puede asegurar que
vayamos a obtener esa calificación